[Music]
hey guys pete here today i'm going to
break down episode 12 of better call
saul's final season and this video will
contain spoilers if you haven't watched
it yet what if you were in love and
alive and you and your partner did
something that made it absolutely clear
that you are poisoned together and then
when you tried to do the right thing and
separate things didn't exactly improve
waterworks is an episode where we see
two very different approaches to that
situation neither is easy to watch but
one is far more destructive and that
will bring gene takavic to a place where
he has a telephone cord wrapped around
his hands as he hovers over an elderly
woman who did nothing to deserve the
situation she's found herself in as
you'd expect from a penultimate episode
of a long-running series there are some
major developments there is one i keep
going back to though and that's kim's
return to saul's office in the breaking
bad timeline i'm not sure exactly when
this is supposed to take place it's been
long enough that he's remodeled it to
look more like the cathedral of justice
that she mentioned back in episode 601
but still some time before he started
working with walter white the first
thing that sticks out is that he sits
and thinks for an hour before he lets
his soon-to-be ex-wife into the office
he can't just open up and let whatever
might happen happen there's a callback
to his time working in the cell phone
store as he bounces a ball off his desk
and thinks about how to approach the
signing of his divorce papers and seeing
kim again as he's done so many times
before he goes with the most frustrating
option i can't help but think a chuck's
decision to tell jimmy that he never
really mattered to him the last time
they saw each other because it wipes me
out in the same way and this could be
the last time they see each other saul
busies himself with his phone and even
takes time for a fist pump while kim
only gets out about 10 words total if
you don't count the um's to her credit
she's sticking to her guns as far as the
decisions she made at the end of episode
609 and saul well he's just dedicated to
not showing any fragment of an emotion
this is just one of many tragic points
in a larger tragic story but what makes
it linger is that we know these
characters enough for this to make sense
and what's worse is that they know each
other kim has seen this before she knows
what she's looking at and on some level
knows there's nothing she can do about
it he shuts down any real chance of a
conversation and she struggles to think
of something to say after his final
words have a nice life kim she can't and
she doesn't and before she can get away
he's already calling in his next client
there are a couple of things worth
mentioning here he calls francesca sweet
cheeks which i suppose at least hints
he's on the path to becoming the person
who uttered the you're killing me with
that booty line right before he's
kidnapped by walt and jesse in his first
episode also his next client is emilio
who will turn out to be the first person
walt kills in the pilot episode of
breaking bad and who you might remember
as a pal of liquefied remains that fall
through the ceiling after jesse fails to
follow walt's instruction when he
dissolves his body emilio was how jesse
heard saul was a criminal lawyer in the
first place and when kim decides to have
a cigarette outside she runs into mr
pinkman himself
the scene wasn't completely essential
there was a brief mention of combo which
was a nice addition but it basically
boiled down to the question of if saul
was actually a good lawyer it was still
great to see these two characters cross
paths though considering they inhabit
similar spaces in their respective
series and we're watching kim leave
saul's orbit and jesse before he's
pulled into waltz these two were both
complicit they went along with what was
happening and kim even drove the bus
towards the end but you got the sense
that it affected them more plus i think
it makes sense for kim to have to think
about this question and i liked the
answer when i knew him he was it
underlines that she's leaving now for
good and has no control over what comes
next for jimmy chronologically this is
the first time that we see them interact
after the fateful night where she told
him that she loved him too but so what
but it isn't the last jump forwards at
2010 and she's living in florida still
not practicing law and no longer
sporting the trademark blonde ponytail
everything is kind of fine i mean she
lives in a house has a decent job and a
boyfriend and i suppose anything normal
might not feel right for her even if
this seems amazingly dull but what
really makes this feel sad is her
avoiding every single decision or chance
to even offer an opinion one i don't
know what do you think is too many and
this is apparently how she goes through
life all the time it's a massive change
from the kim we used to know who never
let other people make decisions for her
she's wearing white sneakers apparently
can't even pick a picture for her puzzle
and what probably hit the hardest was
her not even being able to decide if she
can make potato salad with miracle whip
instead of mayonnaise these are two
different things and it made me a little
bit worried at least until she actually
notices the difference when she's eating
her sandwich at lunch the next day it
all feels so unnatural but she is
actually doing it she's doing the thing
that later will be reminded that jimmy
can't do she's living a life where
there's no chance that she'll
inadvertently cause harm to anyone else
i love the way that director vince
gilligan took the time to focus on how
mundane it actually is and how good she
is at doing this job even though the
stakes are much lower than when she was
a lawyer so that when we get to see the
other end of that phone call from the
last episode it feels like it could
upend everything i looked at everything
that the internet had put together about
this phone call last week and still
couldn't have guessed how it played out
watching her draw the blinds and prepare
after she hears the name victor with a k
saint claire really highlighted how they
both throw themselves into the lives
they've taken on to deal with this thing
that they're having to live with now
he's pushing his way into her new
reality and it makes sense that it's not
what kim says that gets him going on the
phone but that she doesn't say anything
she just says what do you want and
listens he doesn't know what to do with
that and the hurt that comes along with
it and just escalates things on his own
he doesn't even revert to being jimmy
which is the man that she loved and
likely still loves he skips straight to
saw mode and just stays there after she
tells him he shouldn't be calling we
know that she knows about walt and that
saul's on the run and when he keeps
pushing for her to say something she
tells him he should turn himself in then
it's like we're back in that office and
he turns the tables in an instant why
doesn't she turn herself in seeing how
she's the one with the guilty conscience
what's stopping her he throws out that
fring is dead mike is dead and lalo is
apparently dead which i guess might make
her feel safe enough to do what she does
later but there's a moment where he's
almost coming back down as she almost
starts to crack and as he repeats her
name she says i'm glad you're still
alive and hangs up there's a moment
where it feels like it might end there
when she swept up to sing happy birthday
to the receptionist i guess tammy shares
the same birthday as jimmy and it's wild
to see kim put on a smile and sing to
her it doesn't end there though in the
very next scene we see kim arrive back
in albuquerque
there are so many callbacks and
references in this episode that i gave
up on trying to include them all but
there are a couple of things here that
jump out the shot where the sign for
alaska airlines comes into focus makes
you think of jesse's ending and we saw
that this sign used to say wayfarer when
marie was dropping off hank back in
season three there's also this
one-to-one shot of kim walking out the
door that matches walt coming back out
of the airport in season 2 after skyler
dropped him off and after she gets her
rental car and heads to the courthouse
there are of course several things that
jump out mike left his parking lot job
way before he died but now we see that
it's been automated this isn't very
subtle but it does work great to show
how everything's changed none of the
familiar faces are there it's like a
ghost town in a way but everything
continues on there's a bittersweet
moment when she sees the table where
they talk before they got married and
inside she sees a new lawyer with a new
ponytail preparing her client to go into
the courtroom it's not immediately clear
what she's doing at the courthouse but
it comes into focus when she goes to
visit howard's wife cheryl at home she
hands her an affidavit to read and as we
see snippets of that it really does a
great job of showing what they did for
what it was i thoroughly enjoyed
watching them plan and execute this scam
because it was presented in a super
entertaining way looking at it in black
and white through the eyes of someone
who not only lost a loved one but was
denied the truth of what really happened
it hit so much differently there's an
understanding that coming clean doesn't
undo the harm that was caused and she
can't provide real closure since she
doesn't know where the body is but this
is the best that can be done as far as
kim taking responsibility there is no
physical evidence no remaining witnesses
except jimmy and there's a real chance
that the da will decide not to prosecute
cheryl asked him why she's doing this
but it cuts away before we hear her
response it isn't until she's on the
rental car shuttle bus that i realize
she's no longer wearing her trademark
earrings and it's there that we see her
break down and let it all out it builds
slowly and it gets to a point where she
can't hold it in any longer and ray
seahorn delivers one of the most
heart-wrenching scenes of this or any
other series i thought it was an amazing
touch to have the stranger sitting next
to her reach out her hand for comfort
because you have to think that inside
the character's mind that she doesn't
believe she deserves that just a few
scenes back it was as if she didn't
believe she deserved to make her own
decisions and if this turned out to be
the last time we saw kim wexler i could
be okay with that because it was just
that moving i'm not the first one to
bring this up i'm sure i won't be the
last but i really hope that we'll see
ray seahorn win some awards for this
because it's really just an amazing
performance i said that gene skipped
straight to saw mode and stayed there
and we saw that in the last episode we
left him after he broke into the cancer
man's house and we pick up with him in
the same place everything goes according
to plan at first the guy is still
knocked out gene gets all the pictures
he needs and eventually finds his
passwords there's another little
breaking bad reference here when he
looks at his bank statement he has
737 000
in his account which is the same amount
of money that walt thought he needed to
earn in order to take care of his family
after he died jeff returns right on time
and it's here where things take a turn
he has a chance to walk outside but he
decides to take another look around and
starts to pocket some of his expensive
watches the mark wakes up and ends up
blocking his exit by sitting on the
stairs and gene prepares to hit him over
the head with an urn containing the
ashes of his beloved dog rusty so that
he can get past him he won't have to do
that because he passes back out but
considering the way things have been
going since that phone call to kim
it's enough to know that he was ready to
do it it's sort of like when she walked
up to gus's house with a gun it doesn't
matter that she never had to kill him it
matters that she was willing to do that
for jimmy if it hadn't already been
abundantly clear now we know that he's
completely out of control while he's on
his way out a police car pulls up behind
jeff to have their lunch he doesn't know
anything about the subpar fish tacos or
anything else that's going on in the car
and manages to deliver a pretty funny
moment in the middle of a very heavy
episode of television he slams on the
gas and plows into a car just around the
corner so that gene can make his way out
of the house he makes it back home and
waits for the call we see him do his
little magic fingers while he's waiting
like he did way back in season one when
the call comes through jeff informs him
that the cops know there was a robbery
and are trying to pin it on him but
since there's no evidence that he was
involved he tells him to breathe deep
and sit tight he'll have him out by
lunchtime it appears that this shift to
saul is serving him well the only loose
end is that he needs to get marian up to
speed so that she can go over and pay
his bail when he's doing that he makes
another slip up on the phone when he
tells her they just have to pay straight
cash bail and it's nothing like what she
experienced back in albuquerque this
catches her by surprise because he told
her he'd never been there and when he
gets to her house he finds out she's not
ready because she's been looking things
up on her laptop when he opens it up he
sees one of his old commercials and we
see it reflected in color on his glasses
this is a call back to the first episode
when he was watching the vhs tape of the
same commercials and we had the only
other instance of color in any of the
gene scenes what's funny is that it was
hard to imagine how she would learn
about his identity and the solution of
having her put con man in albuquerque
into ask jeez is perfect when she tries
to plug the phone back in to call the
police he rips the cord out of the wall
and we have reached the point where we
believe he might actually be capable of
killing her this is absolutely the most
scary that we've ever seen this
character he does try again to talk her
down and she grabs the life alert panic
button she wears around her neck he
leans in and grabs it too but when she
says i trusted you we see a crack in his
facade he lets her go and she pushes it
when the operator checks on her she
explains the situation and they say
they'll call the police and the episode
ends with jean
saul
jimmy running out of her house
they did it again they made the
inevitable seem truly amazing and they
took us places where we might not have
been expecting to go while having the
characters remain true to who they are a
lot of things i guessed would happen in
this episode did happen but in ways that
it still felt surprising i was wild by
the performances even though i already
know how good these actors are and it's
crazy that they find a way to go to the
next level i can't imagine a way i could
be more excited about the upcoming
series finale this is just a tv show
firing on all cylinders and i can't wait
to see how it ends it's a little
difficult to watch gene goes so
completely dark but there's that part at
the end where there's still a little bit
of humanity inside there he could have
stopped her and he didn't and that
leaves some room for something
interesting to happen in the next
episode i think i'm gonna have to leave
it there so let me know in the comments
what you thought about the episode and
how you think things are gonna end next
week just one episode to go we'll be
talking more about this episode in the
live stream on tuesday so join us for
that and bring your questions please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon